well it's thursday and time for puppy
pig skin picks of the week
sponsored by subaru of las vegas and amy
from the animal foundations here nice to
see you as always see you we have a
beautiful girl here who is this
we have micah and she is five years old
and weighs a good 70 pounds and she's a
shepherd through and through right
well that's what our guess is but of
course we don't know because we don't
get to do a puppy dna on them
but the nice thing is is that she does
like to
get brushed she'll sit and just
take the brush and you can brush her off
she likes attention and she's so sweet
she has a
such a good demeanor yeah really
friendly with everybody out here
yeah well we hope she gets adopted how
did you find her uh
she came in as a stray as a stray okay
well we're gonna let her pick and since
we don't have teams playing this weekend
micah is gonna do the honors of picking
the coin toss heads or tails
for the big super bowl game all right
micah are you ready honey
you want to go for it heads or tails oh
she likes heads
went straight for the dish with heads
good luck whichever team
picks heads micah is adorable she's
50 if you would like to adopt her just
give the animal foundation a call later
today
at the number on your screen
702-955-5901
and because of covid you do have to make
an appointment to meet an
animal there we've got this information
on our website 8newsnow.com
and the animal foundation nate is saying
that they have a big
announcement coming on monday there was
no hint of what that announcement is but
they said stay tuned for that
announcement come monday